[Musica]
c'è qualcosa che accomuna tutti noi
esseri viventi sul pianeta terra
noi tutti siamo soggetti alla tirannia
di un qualcosa di impalpabile
impercepibile di invisibile ma che
comunque lì con noi ogni giorno in ogni
momento della nostra giornata per tutta
la nostra esistenza
questo potente tiranno a nome ben
preciso gravità sì proprio la gravità
quella che vi permette di restare
ancorati alle vostre sete in questo
momento e non volare nel teatro quella
gravità con cui tutte le specie viventi
sulla terra si sono adattate e con cui
hanno imparato a convivere evolvendo per
4 miliardi di anni fino ad arrivare al
giorno d'oggi in cui una particolare
specie che si è voluto su questo pianeta
la specie umana tenta disperatamente di
sfuggire alla gravità ed allora cosa ci
siamo inventati sono aumentati i razzi
queste potenti enormi mentali macchine
che ci possono portare nello spazio ci
portano ad orbitare intorno alla terra
ci hanno portato sulla luna e ci
porteranno su marte
ma vi siete mai chiesti quanto materiale
riusciamo a portare su un altro pianeta
lo portò celeste usando uno di questi
razzi permettetemi di introdurvi al più
alto il più potente il più pesante razzo
ma non sarò dall'uomo il saturn file è
stato il file è stato il razzo stato
dalla nasa durante le missioni apollo
negli anni 60 ed ha portato l'uomo sulla
luna per ben sei volte era alto 110
metri come un palazzo di 35 piani i suoi
motori producevano una spinta di 3,4
milioni di kg come 30 boeing 747 messi
tutti insieme
pensate che il primo stadio dei suoi
motori bruciavano 15 tonnellate al
secondo
di cherosene ovviamente il suo peso era
enorme tremila tonnellate 3 milioni di
kg e partiamo proprio da questo dato da
questi tre milioni di kg 3 mila
tonnellate
se devo a vedere la cosa era composto
questo enorme peso
vediamo che il razzo conteneva due
milioni e mezzo di kg di propellente
quindi la 85 per cento del peso del
sacro file trattato dal propellente un
altro 13,5 per cento del peso era dato
dalla struttura dimensionata per
resistere alle enormi sollecitazioni del
lancio è solo all 1,5 per cento quel
pezzettino lì in alto era il peso del
carico effettivamente utile ma anche lì
se andiamo a vedere il modulo di
servizio e comanda solo orbitato alla
luna e il modulo di atterraggio dopo
aver consumato il propellente per far
atterrare gli astronauti più o meno
comodamente sulla luna
pesava solo sei tonnellate quindi sei
tonnellate sono arrivate sulla luna
partendo da 3.000 tonnellate e lo 0,2
per cento del peso iniziale capite
quindi che abbiamo qualche piccolo
problemino di logistica
quando andiamo nello spazio quando oggi
partiamo per una missione spaziale
portiamo tutto quello che ci serve con
noi la stazione spaziale internazionale
questo meraviglioso avamposto
dell'umanità nello spazio che orbita
continuamente intorno alla terra viene
periodicamente rifornita di cibo acqua
vestiti e tutto quello che serve agli
astronauti per sopravvivere ogni
missione spaziale turn e quindi
completamente dipendente dai
rifornimenti che arrivano a terra e non
c'è modo per gli astronauti di
sopravvivere senza di esse
ma come possiamo allora pensare di
andare ad esplorare con un equipaggio in
mano umano lo spazio per una missione a
lungo termine senza essere in grado di
essere autosufficienti quando siamo lì
come possiamo andare ad abitare un altro
pianeta
potendo portare solo una piccolissima
parte del carico utile con cui partiamo
la terra come posso costruire la mia
casa su marte e creare intorno ad essa
un ecosistema che mi permetta di
dipendere il meno possibile dalla terra
ed essere autosufficiente
se vogliamo continuare ad esplorare lo
spazio dobbiamo cambiare drasticamente
il nostro modo di pensare ed io credo
fermamente che l'unico modo che abbiamo
in futuro per avere delle basi
permanenti su altri corpi celesti passi
attraverso la nostra abilità di imparare
le risorse che sono gialli nello spazio
e trasformare in elementi utili per la
nostra missione la risposta a quasi
tutte le domande e ci siamo fatti finora
si trova qui in questa bellissima foto
di marte prese dal rover curiosity della
nasa dove la maggior parte delle persone
non vede nulla
sono uno sterminato deserto rosso come
in questo caso io vedo invece materiali
guido energie vedo risorse e opportunità
che sono già lì e che non dobbiamo
portarci da terra che possiamo usare in
modo sostenibile e ci tengo a
sottolineare in modo sostenibile perché
a noi ingegneri spaziale sta molto a
cuore il concetto di sostenibilità e km
zero estesa all universo di fronte a
questa foto ci siamo trovati io ed il
mio team due anni fa quando la nasa ha
aperto un bando rivolto a tutti i
migliori scienziati e ingegneri del
mondo molto a scovare le più brillanti
idee su come stampare in 3d una bitta su
marte usando i materiali locali ora sui
di fronting la stampa in 3d è
fondamentalmente esistita sin
dall'antichità quando strutture di ogni
sorta erano costruite strato su strato
usando il materiale che si trovavano
intorno ed uno degli esempi più vicini a
me di questo tipo sono bellissime theory
pugliese vicino e quali sono cresciuto e
trulli sono interessanti perché sono un
vero e proprio esempio di utilizzo dei
materiali locali sulla terra sono
possibili di stratificando l'abbondante
materiale pietroso presente nelle
campagne circostanti
ed allora perché non applicare lo stesso
concetto nello spazio usando robotica e
computer quindi sofisticata tecnologia
usando i materiali che troviamo lì la
sabbia la polvere la regolite marziana
come materiale costruzione usando
l'energia solare per dare energia alle
nostre alle nostre macchine
possiamo quindi utilizzare tutti questi
assetti e trarne vantaggio per la nostra
missione
ma come si costruisce quindi
stampa in 3d una vita su marte è quello
che dobbiamo portarci da terra sono
fondamentalmente due cose molto
importanti ci siano due rover autonomi
che saranno in grado di costruire i
corridoi e le sezioni dell'habitat il
materiale da costruzione abbiamo detto
sarà la regolite malsana regolite il
nome che usiamo per indicare quella
polvere finissima rossa che vede sul
tutte le foto di marte molto simile in
composizione al basato terrestre rohal
basalto lunare i rover inizieranno a
costruire le fondamenta dell'habitat uno
dei due rover sarà capace di
sintetizzare che un processo in cui si
scaldano si scalda la sabbia si fanno
aderire le particelle non le altre
trasformando di fatto la sabbia e roccia
e l'over capace di sintetizzare inizierà
a creare un canale nel quale l'altro
rober verserà la lava con il canale si
sarà raffreddato un altro stato di
sabbia verrà depositato si sintetizzerà
un altro canale
altra lava verrà versata all'interno del
processo continuera finche avremo la
nostra cupola completa quando
arriveranno gli astronauti dovranno solo
installare alcuni elementi per finire la
posizione dell'abi da come gli hair look
sulle porte di sicurezza dalle quali
escono dalla b da tenere la pressione
all'interno la cupola bianca che vedete
in foto è un pezzo di materiale
riciclato dal nostro modulo di
atterraggio è la parte posteriore del
modo di atterraggio che solitamente
viene fatto a schiantare sulla
superficie del pianeta ma anche nel
nostro caso sarà riutilizzata e
diventerà parte integrante della vita
per proteggere i sistemi di
sopravvivenza contenuti di al suo
interno
ora stampare in 3d usando la lava può
sembrare assurdo ed incredibile ma di
fatto è un processo è un approccio
elegante e semplice il nostro processo
di lava casting è ispirato ai flussi di
nava naturali che si trovano sulla terra
ed anche se può sembrare difficile
scaldare e controllare la lava un
processo relativamente semplice infatti
la lava e altamente viscoso e può
scorrere per lunghi tragitti prima di
raffreddarsi permettendo di riempire
perfettamente il nostro canale in questo
modo potremo così costruire delle mura
spesse e resistenti in grado di
proteggere il nostro astronauti nelle
radiazioni cosmiche e dalle piogge di
micrometeoriti un'altra delle domande
che si sono posti prima e come posso
diventare autosufficiente nello spazio
ecco prima di rispondere a questa
domanda vorrei farvi vedere cosa succede
se non siamo autosufficienti nello
spazio e qualcosa va male
ok facciamo segue conti la missione
esplorativa doveva durare
31 sul dl sicurezza hanno mandato liveri
per 68 sola la quantità per 6 persone
ma ci sono solo io quindi ne ho per 300
sulla che se penso di poter arrivare a
400 se direzione quindi devo scoprire
come fare a coltivare del cibo per tre
anni su un pianeta e quello che so nulla
ecco come avrete capito si tratta di un
pezzo del film the march del 2015
in questo film nostro amico astronauta
mark waters viene abbandonato per
sbaglio sulla superficie di marte e del
suo equipaggio perché creduto morto ecco
marca un gravissimo problema un certo
punto si rende conto che il cibo che
nella base non gli basta per
sopravvivere fino all'arrivo dei
soccorsi
fortunatamente marchionne botanico e
dopo aver trovato delle patate nella sua
cucina si ingegna e trova un modo per
coltivarle su marte
usando dei resti organici autoprodotti
ecco c'è una curiosità su questo film
poco prima dell'uscita alla troupe del
film venne a trovarci allo european
astronaut centre per vedere comunque ero
centro addestramento astronauti funzione
furono molto sorpresi nel vedere che noi
stavamo facendo qualcosa di simile a
quello che mart fa nel film non lo
stavano piantando patate ma stavamo
cercando di far crescere pomodori in una
condizione che sarà molto simile a
quella che avremmo su un altro pianeta
gli amici benjamin giovanna stavano
hanno costruito una camera isolata dal
mondo esterno controllata con software
sensori e telecamere in cui hanno
piantato i semi dei pomodori in un
materiale che simula esattamente le
caratteristiche del materiale che
potremo trovare sulla luna o su marte
l'energia solare queste piante l'ha
fornita attraverso delle speciali luci
led che ricreavano un ciclo solare
perfetto e le piante prendevano
nutrimento attraverso l'erogazione con
resti organici autoprodotti della base
quindi urine all'astronauta dai quale
prendevano l'acqua e i nutrienti
necessari e quando abbiamo aperto la
camera quando abbiamo avuto i primi
frutti siamo trovati davanti a questo la
nostra prima insalata
spaziale quindi con questo piccolo
esperimento abbiamo fatto qualcosa di
fantastico abbiamo per la prima volta
creato la vita in condizioni nelle
condizioni in cui le creeremo su un
altro pianeta
ora stampare in 3d una vita su marte non
è una cosa fine a se stessa perché una
delle applicazioni a cui stiamo pensando
e la stampa in 3d di rifugi in zone di
guerra in campi profughi posti dove è
difficilissimo portare materiali come
come nello spazio bossi situati
solitamente vicino deserti dove la
sabbia abbondante e dove il sole e anche
abbondante possiamo usarlo come energia
posti dove la gente vive per anni in
queste condizioni e in un futuro che
vede la popolazione mondiale crescerà a
dismisura e che sarà qualcosa di simile
a questo
un futuro in cui non potremo sfamare
tutti se non iniziando a coltivare in
verticale e non più in orizzontale come
facciamo oggi allora capite che imparare
a creare aiko sistemati sufficienti
e qualcosa che sarà estremamente utile
il futuro per l'umanità
io credo che stiamo vivendo uno dei
momenti più straordinari della storia
dell'uomo qualcosa che fino a pochi anni
fa era caduta solo science fiction o
immaginazione
ogni giorno diventa realtà nel 2030
avremo probabilmente il primo habitat
permanente sulla luna e poco dopo
l'avremo su marte
davanti a noi abbiamo un universo di
possibilità
un universo pieno di risorse e pur non
dimenticando che la storia
dell'esplorazione spaziale umana è una
storia straordinaria ma anche
terribilmente difficile fatta di
determinazione e successi ma anche di
ostacoli e fallimenti continueremo a
andare avanti e andremo ad abitare altri
mondi in futuro
ed allora sì che diventeremo non più
solo cittadini della terra ma cittadini
dell'universo grazie
[Applauso]